here are 12 things you can focus on to
actually make a big impact so let's talk
about that the UN is actually trying to
save the world for about 15 trillion
dollars so you know totally absurdly
large amount you can do it for about two
one thousands of a bit of what the UN
would actually like to spend but what we
shouldn't be doing is to say my
obsession with you know obesity or with
climate change or with plastic straws or
with all these other things take
precedence over the fact that for most
people in this world you know it's
really about the fact that their kids
are dying from easily curable infections
is get bad education are losing out a
product of productivity because of
corruption all these other issues that
we could fix really cheaply so get your
priorities right when you care about the
world and for 35 billion dollars we can
make the change
thank you
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant and returning guest
today uh is the author of a new book
called the best things first Beyond
lombok welcome back to the show thank
you it's so good to have you last time
we were talking about something more
controversial but this what you're
talking about now is how to save the
world exactly it's exciting and and save
the world fairly inexpensively well that
is the exciting part because anyone can
save the world if you give them a
trillion dollars uh you're talking about
a much smaller amount here actually let
me just so you know the UN is actually
trying to save the world for about 15
trillion dollars so yeah it totally
absurdly large amount uh so if you
promise everything to everyone if you
want to you know uh fix the Seas and
hunger and poverty and you know get
everybody organic apples and Community
Gardens and you know fix war and
Corruption and climate change and
everything else the cost is about 15 to
20 trillion dollars and we're spending
about five uh right now so we're missing
about 15 trillion dollars just to give
you a sense of proportion I mean that's
you know there's 15 of global GDP but
it's also more than all the governments
in the world collecting taxes so that's
just not going to happen we're just not
going to be able to have that amount of
money and so what we're trying to say is
wouldn't it be fun if we could do a lot
of it we can't do it all but if we could
do a lot of it the most effective stuff
for very very little money we actually
come out with saying you can do it for
about two one thousands of a bit of what
the UN would actually like to spend so
about 35 billion dollars in my head on
you yes yes yes and and I it's roughly
right so fundamentally for what what is
essentially couch change in the
International Community we could do an
immense amount of good we could save 4.2
Million Lives each and every year that
so yeah that's about 14 of all that die
in the poor half of the world and we
could make each one of these people
almost a dollar richer each and every
day so that's four billion people so
that's about 1.1 trillion dollars this
is just fantastic stuff how do you how
do you get from 30 like they get the
dollars get multiplied massively
absolutely how does that happen so so
for instance one of the things that we
know is that education sucks in most of
the developed or a developing world so
in the developed the world as well that
that is true and and people love to
complain about it and we could probably
make education much much better but
still remember uh the average student in
sub-Saharan Africa is below and far
below the 99th percentile in the UK and
the US so despite the fact that you
think your kids are not learning very
much they're still learning immensely
much more than what happens in in most
of the low and Low Middle income
countries we call them uh the poor half
of the world so the 4.1 billion people
who live in low and lower middle income
countries so these are the people who
live for you know less than 13 a day
often you know the average is probably
what six dollars a day or something very
very little we could help that the the
main reason why education sucks is that
you have we do this universally you put
all the 12 year olds in the same grade
you put all the 13 year olds in the same
grade but remember these 12 year olds
are vastly different some of them are
really really smart and knows what's
going on and some of them have no clue
how are you going to teach a class of 50
when they're so widely you know spread
out you're not you're essentially you're
going to try to aim for the middle and
you're going to miss you know all the
smart kids and all the kids who don't
really know what's going on and that's a
terrible waste what we know works is to
make sure that you teach each one of
these kids at his or her own level now
you can't do that with 50 kids and one
one teacher but what you can do and I'm
just giving one part of the example you
can put them in front of a tablet with
educational software you do that one
hour a day so they're basically you know
in front of this tablet it'll very
quickly find out just exactly how you
know how well Liu on on this topic do
you know a lot or do you know very
little and then start teaching him or
her right at that level if you do that
one hour a day for a whole school year
so the rest of the you know seven uh odd
hours or eight odd hours uh it's still
going to be the same boring class where
you learn very very little and of course
all the other kids are also going to be
using the same tablet that's the way we
keep the cost down if you do that for
one year
each of these students will on average
have learned as much as they normally
would in three years wow so for very
very little money this cost about thirty
dollars per student per year for this
you know you you need solar panels to
recharge them you need to buy the tablet
you need to teach people how to use it
you need a storage so they don't get
stolen all this kind of stuff but if you
do all of that it'll cost thirty dollars
and it'll deliver three years of
learning and that's how you make people
Rich because what happens if you learn
more you become more productive when
you're an adult and you'll have that all
the way through your adult life we can
simply find a way so there's about half
a billion kids in primary school right
now in the lower half of the world if we
make them smarter they will make their
Nations better off not only will they
make their own families better off but
they'll make their Nations richer and so
the whole benefit of that will be in the
order of 600 billion dollars so spend 10
billion dollars on these tablets and
some other things we could also talk
about and then you make them 6 hundred
billion better off in the long run
remember this is actually discounted
back so much of this will happen far in
the future and we're we're heavily
saying that's worth less it's actually
in the order of Six Trillion dollars but
because you're comparing it to now we're
saying it's about 600 billion dollars
that's a phenomenal investment you spend
one dollar you do 65 dollars of good you
spend one pound you do 65 pounds of good
that's how you multiply the world and
again that's how you find really smart
simple things that have amazing impacts
go into and we do
and we the question was like was as I
was reading it going
why haven't people done this before
so the the truth is this is not rocket
science so most people know some of this
stuff so they you know it's well known
that for instance one of the very very
effective things in education is
teaching at the right level and you can
do that with a tablet yeah but if you
ask most politicians what do you want to
do you know a tablet doesn't really look
like anything you want to build schools
and go and cut the cord or you want to
increase Teachers Pay which obviously
make all the teachers want to vote for
you or you want to reduce class sizes
because a lot of parents are are arguing
for that and look all of these things
probably have slight impacts but very
slight compared to the enormous amounts
of of spending so for instance Indonesia
back in the early 2000s they actually
made a constitutional change so they
decided they were going to double
spending on education so they hired
about a million more teachers they have
one of the lowest class sizes in the
whole world uh they doubled spending on
each teacher so they basically double
their pay uh and then they put it out
all over the country uh which you think
that's great right they really care
about education uh unfortunately uh some
people studied this and they uh they
looked at so you know because they
implemented in different regions at
different times you can actually do a
pseudo-randomized control trial and see
how much did it change the uh the uh the
the learning of all these kids turned
out that it had absolutely no impact the
famous paper there's no impact no impact
it the famous paper is called double for
nothing uh so you know it sort of tells
you the whole story there uh it's a very
widely quoted paper it it also
uh looked at how happy are the teachers
and not surprisingly when you double
their pay they're actually much happier
which also you would imagine in the long
run probably mean that they will be
slightly better teachers so we're not
saying that we know everything it seems
reasonable that there will be some sort
of impact but you can measure it at all
so fundamentally there's a lot of wrong
ways to spend enormous amounts of money
and so the answer to your question is
simply it's not that we don't know that
there are some things that work
effectively and there are some things
that are less effective but it's just
we're also trying to do a lot of other
things politicians are trying to be
popular most people are trying to do
stuff that sounds good and you know
looks good on TV and and you have the
feeling that you know I want my kids to
have a lower class size because then he
or she is going to become really smart
but unfortunately the answer is no you
should have her or him in front of a
tablet for an hour a day wow so there's
a lot of parents there who are going to
be very upset because the kid's going to
be like you see the tablet is the way to
go
weren't very happy right because I mean
fundamentally you want your kid to do a
lot better yeah you do you do is it
partly as well beyond is that we're not
being honest about these conversations
people aren't being honest when we're
discussing these topics yes I think so I
mean you know fundamentally uh so the
whole thing sort of stems from the un's
so-called sustainable development goals
uh they were uh they run from 2016 to
2030. this is the global promises that
all governments the UK everybody else
have promised the entire world and they
basically as we started out was they
promised everything to everyone so of
course we're not being honest when we
say we're going to promise you
everything no you're not well you're
going to promise it but you're actually
going to deliver we're failing and
pretty much all of these promises we
promise to deliver all these amazing
things by 2030. uh will probably be half
a century late on this and and there
seems to be no interest in actually
spending a lot of money so what happens
is if you only have a little money and
you spend it on the popular stuff it
obviously means that you'll end up not
having any money for the smart stuff and
and so in that sense yes the book is
really about saying look why don't we do
first the really smart stuff and then
you know please feel free to spend extra
money on all the other stuff but 35
billion dollars that's really you know a
a couch change let's just spend that and
then you know do all the other stuff
that you want well that makes sense
Beyond before we get into the specifics
uh just remind everybody the sustainable
development goals very quickly what were
they and how far or close are we on so
so fundamental I can't I can't tell them
I've worked on these for seven years
nobody can tell you all of them there's
a 169 promises
you know it says amazing things like you
know in poverty which great I'm not sure
anyone really knows how we should end
poverty we can reduce poverty but then
it also goes on to talk about how we
need to make sure that everybody get a
fair wage and we also make sure that
that happens for for Not Just For Men
but for women which is great and for
handicapped people and for uh elderly
people and young people without an
education on and on and then you know it
just goes into the Weeds about
everything we should be doing just on a
little milk and honey oh it's totally it
really is everything and then of course
it goes on to disease and say we should
get rid of disease I think that's a
great idea I'm not sure how we would do
that yeah again uh you know we can get
rid of uh infectious disease or pretty
much
but you know you need to have your
conversation about which ones should we
do first and how much should we do it
some of it's realistic some of it is not
but then you know communicable sorry
non-commutable diseases so the stuff
that you you know the chronic disease
we're not going to be able to get rid of
that uh and they've promised to so they
have more moderate they promising we
should cut it by one-third uh we're no
way uh uh on on the path of that right
now we're we're just not re achieving it
at all and again it it's just
unrealistic and then they go through all
these other things uh so it's a lot of
wonderful thoughts but nothing is
actually happening and that's why if you
if you try to estimate the total thing
and believe me that's very very hard to
do uh but uh Jeffrey Saxon some of these
people that new in New York have
actually tried what they find is that we
are getting better but that's
fundamentally because the world is
getting better so you know not
surprisingly the sdgs actually sort of
indicate something that's nice so it is
getting better but it's getting better
very slowly there is no pickup after
2016 when we started uh doing the sdgs
so there's been no sort of yeah we all
want to do it it's just the same uh path
as it was before and if you follow that
path remember covet totally broke that
but if you imagine we sort of Follow
that path for the rest of this decade
we'll be Far Far Away we'll probably
only get to uh what we promised half a
century late makes sense so the story is
that you you're saying is basically
we're throwing a hell of a lot of money
at a wide range of things because we
want to deliver all things to all men
and here are 35 billion 12 things you
can focus on to actually make a big
impact so let's talk about that what are
the biggest things that we actually
should be looking at Beyond so we should
be looking at education as I talked
about and then we should look at some of
these other things so let me give you
one other example I'm not going to do
all 12 uh but uh one obvious thing is
maternal and newborn Health uh so uh the
thing yeah again I uh I learned a lot
when I was writing this book because I
work with some of the smartest
economists and they again work with all
these people who actually do the stuff I
I'm not an expert on this they are and
I've just learned a lot from them so uh
one thing that surprised me was so many
moms are still dying from childbirth so
about 300 000 moms die each and every
year in this world and they needn't do
that in childbirth uh 2.3 million kids
die each and every year and first 28
days in their life on Earth that's just
terrible and again totally totally
unnecessary so much of this is because
there is complications during birth and
there's no materials to to handle that
so the mom has uh preeclampsia or
eclampsia basically high blood pressure
and she bleeds out uh we know how to fix
that we fix that routinely in the rich
world we should make sure moms get into
institutional birth give give birth in
institutions instead of just doing it at
home
so that there is an opportunity to treat
her if things go wrong likewise you know
and again I didn't know this at all uh
so most kids that come out of mom just
start breathing right away about 80 so
15 percent need a slap in the back to
get going and then they start breathing
that's fine but even in rich countries
about five percent of all kids just
don't breathe wow so you need to start
giving you you need to push in air into
their lungs and then and then they go
and then they survive right so and of
course we just do that in rich countries
isn't that rocket science you just need
a simple uh hand pump I mean in rich
countries we have something more fancy
because we can't have such easy things
right but but in in in in the poor part
of War you just often don't have this
hand pump it costs 65 for each of these
hand pumps it works for probably three
years and in that in that time you could
probably save about 25 kids 65 25 kids
why are we not doing that and
everybody to rush out and do a gofund
just for this hand pump it's about
getting all of these things so you know
for instance uh uh disinfectants yeah
you'd imagine that's a good idea to have
disinfectants and on the surfaces in
your hospital Wing but again we don't
and and so a lot of places do but you
know about a fifth don't we should make
sure that that has it there and so the
point with this argument is really just
to tell people if we focus more on
maternal and newborn Health that's by
making sure that the women come in uh to
institutional births so about uh
two-thirds of doing it now we want
almost all in institutional birth and
that these institutions actually have
midwives that they have disinfectants
they have this hand pump these very very
simple things World Health Organization
has a whole list of this if you did all
of that it would cost about five billion
dollars a year so not nothing
but then you could save 166 000 moms
each and every year and you could save
1.2 million kids each and every year
it's just yeah it just blows your mind
that we're not doing this and and the
simple reason why we're not doing it is
because it has very little sort of
public awareness uh I don't know have
you guys ever seen the uh this is the
Monte python sket uh skit with uh the
machine that says playing no no you have
it's a a uh uh the meaning of life you
oh God you've got to say that anyway so
uh they're they're these doctors uh uh
in in an operating room or something uh
and they have all these machines and
they're all totally excited about the
machines and the uh and the manager of
the hospital comes in and he's then they
oh let's show him the machine that says
pling which is apparently the most
expensive machine in the hospital so
everybody is very excited about it and
then at one point John Cleese goes
still something missing man
[Music]
patient yes where's the position
patience they're so excited about these
expensive machines that they forget that
this is about the woman and you know she
it's funny and she get just neglected
all the time and they want to emphasize
the machine that says playing right I
mean and and you know obviously it's a
character and and you know I'm not
saying that all doctors are like that
but Dr is probably rather would have an
MRI scanner than they would one of those
hand pumps right because you know it's
fun to go to a conference and say yes we
have this you know this new MRI scanner
2000 or whatever it's called but you
know this hand pump oh yeah old old
stuff but it's actually this hand pump
that'll help save uh 25 kids because in
some ways you know when you've got
people in sitting around a room in the
U.N and they're all very intelligent
they almost desire complex Solutions
because
it's more grandiose isn't it than
something as simple and as prosaic as a
hand pump yes but but it's not that they
haven't promised also to fix this right
because they promise everything but but
the point is that when you're promising
everything you have no direction if you
have 169 priorities you have no
priorities right yeah and if you promise
everything you inevitably leave it to
people to say hmm would I rather have a
cheap hand pump that nobody cares about
oh would I like a lot of expensive stuff
and a new hospital wing and you know all
these other things uh so you know the
the truth is we almost inevitably end up
doing stuff that's less effective not
because people are bad but because they
have lots of other incentives apart from
you know doing the best things first and
so that's why I think by making this
book and by forcing everyone to sort of
confront the fact that there is some
incredibly effective things we can do it
becomes a little harder to not do that
first
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear in London I have since found out
this has very different meaning we've
all had a night that's got out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we used it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we heard hugely successful trip it is
very economical and I felt strong enough
to wrestle American bear which we all
know is grotes to the week compared to
Great Russian Bear if you're looking for
a simpler and cost effective supplement
routine ag1 is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try edgy1 and get five free edu1
travel packs and a free one-year supply
of vitamin D with your first purchase go
to drink ag1.com trigonometry that's
drink ag1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like me
you know the thing that you talked about
in your book which really resonated with
me and everyone can drink now my
mother's Venezuelan so Venezuela is the
fifth biggest oil producer in the world
it should be actually with the largest
oil reserves in the world it should be
arguably one of the richest countries in
the world it should be on the same level
of Saudi Arabia but because of chronic
mismanagement and to put it more
accurately corruption
it has never reached those Heights and
most likely tragically never will and
when you see in the third world that is
the real problem for me that is a cancer
which means that we talk about Education
Health all of these things but a lot of
the time it's because these funds are
being leached by people in higher
positions so how do we solve corruption
Beyond because that is one of your
points yes which I will say just
throughout the Francis point being from
Russia I was like I I like everything
else Beyond saying this seems a little
bit unrealistic
I will answer the corruption question
just before I've said that all of these
uh uh approaches actually assume that
there will be corruption and that people
will be incompetent and that people will
you know steal some of the uh the
tablets so this is all based on
reasonably large-scale experiments where
you you've gone out to do this for a
region for instance for the for the
tablets so we know that some of them are
going to get stolen we know that some of
the teachers just don't care and we know
that all these things so if you assume
sort of basic incompetency as as much of
the world has then it's uh 65 dollars
back so we're not assuming sort of oh if
everything was wonderful then we can get
65 no if everything was wonderful it'd
probably be much much higher so so we
include that people are less than ideal
right but back to the uh to the
corruption point so corruption costs uh
a lot of money we don't quite know for
for obvious reasons it's hard to survey
uh so a popular estimate that also seems
reasonably well sourced is that it cost
about a trillion dollars in the world so
we're basically losing about one percent
of of global GDP to corruption so
absolutely there's a lot of ways the
corruption is just terrible and of
course for Venezuela it's been much much
worse I don't know about rush but I
wouldn't be surprised yes yes so
um how do you fix it well there's a lot
of ways that you don't know how to fix
it but we've actually found one and
again this is not us you know this is
this is uh uh evidence that we know out
in the literature that the biggest
consumer of so the biggest uh uh demand
for most products in the world actually
come from governments when they procure
stuff so anyone anywhere from you know
Post-it notes to roads but obviously
roads and that kind of stuff are much
much more expensive so it really is when
you ask for roads so are there
infrastructure project these are
typically hugely corrupt so we did work
in Bangladesh and you know the sort of
standard understanding is that you have
uh they have British laws and so you
hand in and seal an envelope with your
bid in a government office uh but the
problem is it's only advertised in a
really really small uh uh and obscure
Journal so only a few people see it and
then you know the local Elite already
has decided uh you're going to have that
bid right and so they put up goons
outside that office so you can't
physically come in with the bid and so
they get the bid at at an outrageous
rate right if you did e-procurement so
basically put this online a little bit
like eBay there's a lot more to it right
but fundamentally it's just simply if
the government said we'd like a road who
wants to bid on it uh online you can
still be corrupt and you can still make
some sort of uh impacts but it's much
harder everyone will hear about it a lot
more people are going to bid for it so
that bids down the price typically you
also get higher quality but crucially
it's much easier to flag if people are
sifting off a lot of money they'll
probably still be sifting off some money
but less and so what we find is on
average uh this simply this approach
simply makes governments about 6.75
percent more effective they simply get
you know more more for their money we
told this to the uh to the Bangladeshi
Finance Minister you know our
calculations basically show that if you
do eat procurement you can get 700
million dollars more stuff every year
how's that not cool for a finance
minister now the problem is of course he
knows that the people just below him are
a couple of layers down below they're
actually making a lot of money off of
being corrupt so you have to have the
political will to do and that may be
what you were sort of it's not going to
work but we know it works in a lot of
countries but there's still 70 countries
in low and Low Middle income countries
that haven't completed the uh the
e-procurement journey it cost trivial a
little so we're talking about you know
five ten million dollars per country uh
uh and and there's some you know add-on
effects we estimate about 72 million
dollars this is this is nothing uh and
it would generate about 10 billion
dollars in more purchase opportunity
remember it's mostly smaller countries
that that are still not implemented this
we're simply saying that's an easy win
is not going to work for everyone not
everybody is going to have the political
will to do it and there'll still be
corruption but less so this is just an
incredibly easy win and and again we
don't fix all corruption but we fix some
of it and that's you know the point here
is again get we need to get out of this
oh we got to fix the whole problem you
know we got to fix all of uh health or
all of Education or something no we need
to do better than we did before
this is kind of one of the things that's
happened isn't it we've we've somehow
got ourselves locked into this
maximalist mindset where it's like all
or nothing either either you do it you
and we have this conversation in this
country about all sorts of pro the NHS
you know we must fix the NHS it's if the
labor and power they broke it if the
Tories are in power they broke it and
and so people a phrase that I heard
occurred in the last couple of days that
I really like is trade-off denialism
yeah we seem to be there on on a lot of
these issues look fundamentally the
world is about trade-offs and we all
know that in our personal lives right I
mean if we're going to replace the roof
so it doesn't drip in you can't afford
your summer holiday and we know this and
well you know some people will max out
their credit cards but eventually
they'll find out that there's a that
there is a trade-off right and you have
to make these trade-offs but of course
politicians are elected on the promise
of being able to promise more than the
other guy and that inevitably leads to
everyone promising everything to
everyone and then we all get
disappointed which is bad setup uh so at
least what we're trying to say is look
why don't we do the smartest stuff first
and then we can do all the other stuff
you're talking about but you know let's
just set aside 35 billion dollars and
the again the the point in some ways and
and it's important also to say when we
say we I'm not saying you know I don't
have 35 billion dollars in the couch or
anything I don't think you guys do
either right so this this is about
government so this could be the UK
government spending its development Aid
it could be a lot of developing country
government so India could decide all
right we're gonna you know get more
tablets out to our uh to our
constituents it could be You Know Rich
billionaires like Bill Gates or Elon
Musk that we're going to say all right
I'm gonna you know spend my money they
couldn't do all of them uh but you know
they could do one or two uh so it's
about getting everyone to think a little
smarter about this well that's the
exciting thing about what you're saying
is you almost don't need any new money
you just need to take some of the money
that you're spending on other things and
put it into this stuff that makes more
impact so we've got education we we've
got the corruption we've got the the the
health the maternity stuff we talked
about uh what about disease because
there are some diseases that are
absolutely
illuminable if that is a word malaria
for example right yes tell us about some
of that stuff so malaria is is one of
those things you know you you think and
certainly the way we've conceptualized
malaria is that it's a tropical disease
and that's because almost all of it is
now in Africa but that's not true no
it's not William uh
Oliver Cromwell died of malaria this
country is called ague because you
wouldn't even know that that's a good
fact yeah because we were there was
marshlands in in Cambridge yeah malaria
is not all bad yeah exactly the Irish
loves
but but actually yes exactly you know
Russia had lots and lots of malaria and
Archangel and uh in Moscow in Finland it
was uh endemic in 36 states of the US in
the early part of last century uh so
malaria has been a problem everywhere in
the world we fixed it because we got
richer and because we got more resilient
and because when you have when you're
sufficiently rich you also buy kinin
back then you know drugs so you get rid
of it and then you basically don't have
malaria again you know if someone come
flies in with malaria in England it's
not like oh my God then everybody gets
malaria again we just make sure that uh
he or she gets treat it and then it's
it's that's the end we didn't get rid of
the mosquitoes we just got rid of the
the parasite that's inside the
mosquitoes that's actually causing
malaria the problem with uh Africa is
that they have especially bad mosquito
that so a lot of other mosquitoes like
to bite animals as well and that means
you dilute the problem a lot if you get
a lot of livestock basically a little
just you know uh uh what do you say
they'll Sting the uh the livestock
instead and they won't transmit the
malaria but unfortunately the malaria
that's uh the malaria mosquito in Africa
almost exclusively by humans so that's
much much harder and then they also have
a parasite the malaria parasite that
specific one is much more deadly uh so
that's sort of a double combo that means
this we we've been able to do it in the
rest of the world but not in in Africa
now by far the best way to deal with
that is to get long long lasting
insecticide treated bed nets uh
mosquitoes typically bite at night if
you put up a bed net and sleep under it
uh you both make sure that the mosquito
can't get to you and because when it
sits on them on the bedside because it'd
like to get to you uh it actually gets
the pesticide and then it dies so we
know this is the way to do it now if you
hand out bed nets not all of them are
going to be used well uh some of them
are going to be used for fishing and
other stuff you know there's there's or
Bridal you know there's all these
stories about how you how you do
different things with them but if you
distribute more you're going to get more
people to sleep on them and that means
not only these people will be saved but
also you make it much harder for the
most mosquito to keep transmitting the
uh the uh the malaria
um sorry I'm now forgetting what it's
called but the malaria
um parasite parasite thank you that's
that was the word I was looking for uh
so that actually becomes much more rare
so this is the way we do it so we looked
at how much would it cost to get all
nations in Africa all these 27 Nations
that have most of the malaria up to 90
coverage they're about 70 right now and
that has a cost it's about 1.7 billion
dollars a year so not trivial but you
could save about 200 000 people just
doing that and not only that you would
also make these people much much more
productive because malaria is typically
not deadly so the 200 000 people that
die yep that's terrible and that's a
real cost but the vast number of people
so we're talking about 500 million
people get sick much many of them
several times a year that's a terrible
disease and you have it for you know 5
to 15 days where you basically can't do
anything and so you lose out on
productivity many countries in Africa
you have to hire two people because you
know one of them is going to be sick
with malaria and that's of course
incredibly unproductive so not only do
we save 200 000 people but we also make
them much more productive so again these
are Simple Solutions and again it's not
that we don't know this but it's also
just one of the many many many many
things people are talking about and so
we're trying to say well let's talk
about this first yeah and tuberculosis
is also something you touch on
tuberculosis is you know that's the
that's just a phenomenal thing so
fourth of everyone who died in the 1900s
died from tuberculosis every fourth
person in Europe that died back then
died from tuberculosis it probably the
biggest killer in the world so over the
last 200 years it probably killed about
a billion people we you can't wrap your
head around that and we were incredibly
worried about it in in Europe and
elsewhere until we figured out oh we can
cure it with you know with uh
antibiotics and so it dropped off our
radar and we're like okay that's fixed
then nobody gets you know nobody dies
from tuberculosis today in rich
countries but that never happened in
many countries in the global South so
they still saw a decline uh but you know
India and just before uh its uh
Independence in 1946 estimated about
half a million people died from
tuberculosis each and every year
last year the World Health Organization
estimated that half a million people
died from tuberculosis in India now
they've brought it down fourfold but the
population has grown four-fold as well
and that's why it's still the same
number we need to do something about
that and we know how to fix it so the
simple point is you need to get more
people to take their medication that's
actually hard because you need to take
it four to six months but it's fairly
cheap and we know how to do it and you
need to make sure that everyone do this
so you you know you get sort of uh
tuberculosis Anonymous where everybody
gets together and say yes I took my my
uh my pills all the way through the week
kind of thing and you give them little
prizes like uh like juice boxes or
something and it feels a little odd that
we have to do that in order to get
people to take the medication but if you
don't get treated for tuberculosis you
on average will transmit it to 10 to 15
other people so it's a great investment
it's a little bit like when we
distributed condoms for HIV AIDS it's
just a good way to make sure that
everybody else don't get it and then the
other part is we need to find so we
estimate about 12 million people get TP
every year but we only diagnose about
seven so we still have a lack of people
that we're that we're finding and those
are the ones that keep transmitting it
to new ones and that's what's keeping
the uh the infection rate going we know
how to fix it we just need again about
5.5 billion dollars a year and then we
could save over this decade about six
hundred thousand over the next three
decades about a million people each
sorry how are you going to find the
people that we we don't know the
transmission yes yes that's a very good
question so uh it's often very uh poor
people it's people in slum areas uh so
BRAC and uh which is the world's biggest
NGO in in Bangladesh they had old
typically uh uh widowed women walking
around they would have like 15 families
that were their responsibility so they'd
go there every second or third day and
say so how are they how are people have
anyone been coughing for a long time and
then you know if if you've been coughing
for three weeks then they say shouldn't
I take you to get tested the problem
here is tuberculosis is actually a
really uh stigmatizing disease uh so you
know for instance uh if you get
tuberculosis in Kenya about a fourth of
everyone who gets it get divorced
their partner just says bye right
because it feels do I want my kids there
uh when he's coughing and maybe not
getting getting well I don't want to be
the one the wife of the guy who has
tuberculosis everybody else is going to
shun me at the market I know you're
trying to save the world mate but the
problem is you're really doing down the
concept of marriage here everyone's
watching this guy oh the no one takes
their wedding vows as seriously anymore
I'm sorry and and you lose your job
because people don't want to have a guy
with tuberculosis hanging around right
and and so actually Allah lot of people
want to lie about do I have tuberculosis
right you actually go to the doctor
especially if it's a private sector
doctor he makes money off of you coming
again so he will have an incentive to
tell you no it's not tuberculosis right
and given that it's a little hard to
diagnose there's a good chance he's
against this and and you know many of
the symptoms are similar to a lot of
other diseases he'll basically say no
here's a Vic right kind of thing I'm not
saying that that's exactly what happens
but it has this tendency and everybody
sort of wants to believe that I didn't
have tuberculosis because then my wife
won't leave me and my I won't lose my
job and all that stuff so we need to
make sure that people actually go
through this so you do that by actually
testing people you test people in in
prisons and and uh mining camps and slum
camps and and uh refugee camps that kind
of thing uh you possibly and we have new
Gene tests that are very cheap and
effective but you need to set up the
system to do that and it you know it has
real cost if you're going to mass a lot
of people but all of that is included in
the 5.5 billion dollars so again it's
not that we don't know how to it's even
not that most of the world's governments
haven't already promised I mean yes
they've promised everything but they're
actually extra promised this money but
still haven't delivered so you know
we're simply just saying let's again do
the stuff that we have promised and
that's incredibly effective so for every
dollar spent uh you'll do about 46
dollars worth of good beyond what is the
connection between TB and AIDS and is
that a part of the problem with the
stigma element to it because we all know
that when the immune system collapses it
becomes very vulnerable the body becomes
very vulnerable to certain diseases and
TB unfortunately finishes off a lot of
AIDS patients yes so there is a
connection uh in the typical setup and
the all the numbers I've given you are
actually without the HIV and so for you
know and there's a lot of different ways
to think about that the Health Community
is simply decided to say the people who
die from TB but because they are HIV
died from HIV which I think makes sense
so it's a it's sort of a separate
problem the main problem is not TB
because they would probably have died
from something else had they not gotten
HIV treatment so it's a different
conversation it's one that we mostly
have fixed so again remember uh HIV
kills much much less than for instance
TB it kills around 600 000 so about the
same number as malaria uh whereas TB the
on HIV TB kills about 1.4 million people
so again TB is the world's leading
infectious disease killer it wasn't in
2020 and 21 because covet uh but it's
been for the last 10 years besides covet
I find that not really surprising so HIV
AIDS only kills 600 I mean it only kills
it yeah I I would have thought it'd be
much much bigger yes but and that's
because you think about back in the
early 2000s where it was huge and they
had the the real opportunity to take
over the continent of of Africa uh and
so it was incredibly good that we got a
lot of drugs out uh and actually managed
to to deal with HIV but it's partly
because we have managed to deal with HIV
and also because it got so much
attention that now we should still
remember that HIV is an important
disease but it's much much harder to
find these really really effective cheap
solutions but going forward that's also
why this is not one of our Solutions and
it also shows you you know the the
impact of of prioritization it does mean
that we don't say we should do
everything now I'm not saying we should
cut back on HIV but I'm simply saying
this is not the first place where we
should spend more money because it turns
out that you can probably only spend you
know a pound and do say five pounds
worth of good which is great but it's
not nearly as great as spending a pound
and doing 46 Pounds of good so we're
simply pointing out you know the stuff
that you should do the very first and
obviously immunization is a massive part
of this yes so immunization is what
saved most of us uh we have this whole
conversation about covet I'm just gonna
totally ignore it but but we know that
childhood immunization is an incredibly
good thing to do so you know measles
would probably kill two or three million
kids each and every year if we didn't
vaccinate we vaccinate most kids in the
world and that means we only see about
80 000 deaths each and every year that's
a fantastic outcome remember uh uh no
well you probably don't but smallpox
smallpox was you know one of the world's
leading infectious disease Killers it
probably killed somewhere between 300
and 500 million people in the 20th
century we eradicate catered that in
1978 that was an incredibly good
investment we actually go through the
cost there one of the reasons why we
could eradicate it is because it doesn't
have a an animal Reservoir so most
diseases if we get rid of them and
humans they'll still survive in animals
and then they'll come back and perhaps
literally bite us later on and then
we're back but smallpox didn't and so
you could actually eradicate it we
eradicated with a vaccine yeah so this
was the world's first vaccine it came
from cowpox so uh yenner back in in the
1700s uh realized which a lot of other
people are also pointed out that the
milkmaids didn't have uh didn't get
smallpox because they got cow pox first
from the cows and so he took their
cowpox and put it into a a young guy and
then infected him with uh with smallpox
to see if he survived this would not
have passed the ethics
but no so you could do that I know I'm
not sure he actually told him the whole
the full scale of what he was doing and
that's why science doesn't work yes this
is what we need to more no no too much
red tape yes I'm not arguing for that
but I am arcing for that we're we're
vaccinating a lot of people uh a lot of
kids get vaccinated but we're not
vaccinating as many as we could so we
could still save more people from uh uh
measles from uh from uh uh uh sorry
there's a lot of things in there and I
now I'm forgetting most of them but uh
rotaviruses for instance which are one
of the things that give uh most of the
diarrheas uh that often lead to about
half a million kids dying certain us as
well yes uh and yes I'm guessing too
polio is a difference well it's a
different uh task there's very very
little polio left and so the main
challenge with polio is really that we
can't get to the places where people
still have polio because we you know
people there believe that they're
actually you know the Bill Gates trying
to put in uh microchips or or more worse
that they're that they're that we're
trying to limit their population because
we don't like Muslims there are a lot of
uh you know sort of uh uh um uh
conspiracy theories about that but it's
not mainly uh a monetary problem anymore
it's more a political issue uh so these
are this is much more about getting
people from you know most of these uh
poor countries from 80 to say 90 or 95
uh and it's going to be costlier it's
going to be harder but what we find is
it's going to save so many people that
for every pound you spend you'll do 101
pounds worth of good wow it's just
simply a fantastically good way to save
about half a million uh kids do you
sometimes get frustrated beyond that
you're in this field and you see the way
that people talk about vaccination
immunization and look you know let's
forget about covid but the the fact that
this the sort of an anti-vaxx movement
seems to be growing to me I find
incredibly worrying yes but and yes I do
get frustrated but remember I I deal
with so many other stupid weird things
that it's just one of the many things
yeah at some point you just have to let
go and say yes this is annoying but you
know it's part of a world where people
are too much time and and they're quite
frankly so well off that they can afford
you know you would never do that if your
kids were regularly dying from measles
and what we find is you know these
people who think oh my kids shouldn't be
vaccinated against measles uh when they
discover that there's a death nearby or
even their own kid they certainly want
to vaccinate the next kid so you know it
sort of shakes people back into reality
I think and yes that was an unnecessary
death and I would wish that people
didn't do it uh but you know most people
get this most people actually get that
science and progress is mostly a good
thing uh and that you want to do mostly
what your doctors tell you just simply
because it
it is beyond coming back to the bigger
issue can I ask just slightly sort of
quest skeptical question which is uh I'm
I'm you're you and the people you're
working with a lot smaller than me so
I'm assuming you've thought of this
obviously but a lot of the the poorer
countries in the world many of the
things you're talking about it's not
that it's not only that they don't have
the particular Gadget or whatever that
they need but it's an infrastructure
issue there aren't roads there aren't
trains there aren't whatever
um is that something that you guys have
thought about and included in these
calculations
yes so you know I'm saying yes I think
we've included almost all of it so a lot
of this is based on what's called
randomized control trials so you
actually you know you do this in some
Villages and you don't do it in other
Villages and you see what happens uh and
so all of these bad things that was what
we talked about before the corruption
the incompetence and the fact that
there's no roads or there's poor roads
is sort of baked into the result because
we did it in real world situations so
we're assuming that if the world can do
what we did in these villages in this
region then we've already baked in all
the all the bad all the bad things so
for instance we we look at uh uh making
more research and development for uh for
uh better agricultural productivity
remember what basically got us rich and
what got us the fact is most people
don't work in agriculture that's that's
how we get rich right if everybody has
to work in agriculture there's nothing
else to do so you want to get much
higher productivity in agriculture we
did that not partially through the Green
Revolution where you got better seeds
for rice and uh and wheat and Maize or
corn uh so that you could grow a lot
more for every hectare or acre you you
farm but we didn't do that and the poor
part of the world because they don't
have much money and that quite frankly
wasn't our main concern so kasawa and
sorkum and all these other things that
people grow in in low-income countries
we should make those work better but and
we know how to do it and we we suggest
we should be spending about 5.5 billion
dollars on this every year on average
and that would actually generate much
higher yields which would benefit
farmers and benefit consumers Farmers
because they produce more consumers
because each product will cost less and
then you'll have many fewer people
starving but your point is exactly but
what about the roads what about the
infrastructure what about do they have
irrigation do they have mechanization no
they still lack a lot of stuff but the
beauty of this is if you hand out a
better casawa and I'm not really sure
how exactly how big that is but it's not
a seed I don't even know what that's
according it's it's sort of a potato
kind of yeah date in South America yes
so if you hand out that you can grow
this and make it grow more make more
kasawa but even if you don't have the
irrigation even if you don't have the
mechanization now had you had that you
would be doing even better but you can
do that without all of those extra
inputs and that's what's the beauty of
much of this so it works somewhat but
you know everything could be better but
that's our goal is not to make the world
fantastic I mean that'd be wonderful but
that's not what we're trying to do we're
simply trying to make it better you're
going for the super low hanging fruit
that made the biggest impact and that's
why you're focusing on the poor half of
the world yes what I I what did occur to
me as you were talking though is it's
weird how uh half the world is starving
essentially or as close to that point
and in the west the one of the biggest
causes of death is we have too much food
and we ourselves into an early grave is
there a low hanging fruit there that we
can do because it'd be quite nice to to
do to deal with that as well otherwise
we're going to make the whole world fair
and and die early as well yes
we haven't looked at that so
um there there's a there's a a moral
part of this and then there's the
Practical part so very clearly the moral
part is it's a much better situation to
end up eating too much food than too
little because you can sort of regulate
that yourself clearly we can't but at
least but but at least you know if I
have to choose I'd much rather have this
position 100 so we should just make sure
that this is not a symmetrical issue no
no but but you're absolutely right and I
I don't think there's a there's an
obvious way to do this because you know
we're involved as I as I understand
we're involved to say you know food
could you know eat as much of it and and
preferably sweet and and fat because
that then we'll put on a lot of weight
for when winter comes finally I guess
they agrees with me wonderful so so yeah
we're we're basically fighting our genes
and I'm not sure exactly how you how you
get around that uh now there's a lot of
other things that we can do and people
will argue that we should have uh cities
where you walk more I mean if you look
in New York and other cities where you
walk many many cities in Europe people
are just not just less fat and it's also
it's good for your General Health and
all kinds of other things it probably
also makes for better uh sort of culture
and and social interaction so maybe we
should be focusing on that but the point
again is this is not the kind of stuff
where you spend a dollar and get amazing
returns so this is the kind of thing
that rich countries can focus on and I
love us focusing on it and and again
we're rich we can actually do several
things we can walk and chew gum at the
same time so we should be focusing on
these issues as well but what we
shouldn't be doing is to say my
obsession with you know obesity or with
climate change or with the plastic
straws or with all these other things
take precedence over the fact that for
most people in this world you know it's
really about the fact that their kids
are dying from easily curable infectious
disease get bad education are losing out
of productivity because of corruption
all these other issues that we could fix
really cheaply and Beyond this is where
we come to what I think your your up
against with all of this which is is
foreign
and awareness of the rest of the world
in the west where we have the money to
be able to put into fixing these things
easily because uh I grew up for a
portion of my life in Uzbekistan I saw
people with tuberculosis I saw people
you know I I have some kind of thing
with TB where I I was vaccinated against
it but I had some kind of reaction
anyway like that's a real thing I I and
most people in the west haven't had that
experience they haven't been there and
also we're not well educated on on the
trade-off conversation which we had
earlier which is like you have a limited
pool of resources
how do you best use it instead of going
I want everything right so it's also
like a there's something in the way that
we think about problems that seems off
to me do you see what I'm saying how do
we fix that because if we can fix that
then this becomes automatic this becomes
you don't even need to write this book
then yeah all right so I don't want to
take the book away from you no you're
right honestly I don't think you can fix
that because it's not surprising if you
don't have tuberculosis in your entire
country it's not a big thing in your
mind yeah uh Hume uh once wrote the
famous philosopher in the 1700s in
Scotland uh that you know I can read
about a big catastrophe in China in the
newspaper and then I turned the page and
it cuts my finger and all I care about
is my finger right I mean you're just so
like this is how the world works you
know honestly we don't care all that
much about it's true far off the world
so I I I I don't think that's
necessarily bad you know that's how we
we couldn't handle a world where we had
to worry about everything all the time
we'd be you know nervous wrecks so it's
much more about saying when you care
about the world when you not don't just
care about you know God I gotta get the
kids to you know soccer and I need all
this other stuff but when you care about
the world then you start thinking about
okay I want to make sure I care rightly
about the world and we often end up
carrying you know the these sort of
plastic straw argument which is you know
nice I don't want plastic in the ocean
uh there's a lot of other conversations
we can have about that but you know it's
perhaps also good to get a sense of
proportion is this really the biggest
problem in the world no it's not you
know the biggest problem is that a lot
of kids die and a lot of kids don't get
education all these things that we've
talked about so get your priorities
right when you care about the world and
and I think you know if you look at what
the world spends on the world it's
perhaps one percent of its GDP that's
nice you know that sort of suggests yes
I care mostly about my finger but every
once in a while I care about people who
are uh you know suffering in China when
we then spend that one percent let's
make sure we spend it well and remember
again one percent is much much more than
what I'm uh talking about here so let's
just get that right and look that's what
we're doing right here yeah completely
now we talk about immigration a lot on
the show and you know the positives and
negatives a bit but you've written a
very positive uh chapter on immigration
so let's get into that yes
so so first of all
um there's some economists out there who
points out and I think that's a good
point uh that the world is hugely
misallocated in labor so if you have a
person who works in McDonald's in
Nigeria that person makes about it 15
times less than the same person doing
the same job in a McDonald's in the U.S
that seems to suggest that you're just
simply much more productive in a rich
World setting we certainly know that we
like to believe that the reason why
we're making a reasonable I don't know
about you guys uh but yeah they don't
send enough money man yeah exactly these
guys are actually making very little
money yeah
but but yeah in the rich World we're
making pretty good money we like to
believe that that's because we're really
smart
but the truth is most of this is because
we're among a lot of other smart people
and we're incredibly productive in this
part of the world so economists would
argue that maybe we should move a large
part of the world
to the West because that would make them
much more productive remember these are
all the poor people we could make them
much richer by moving to the West now
that's a you know that's an intriguing
argument and and you know what they find
is just some people you know it's an
intriguing I'm not saying inside them a
a wonderful thing or anything uh so they
estimate we could double the world's GDP
we could basically make the world twice
as rich and that would solve a large
part of the inequality problem of the
world now it would also make an insane
amount of political problems so that's
not what we're suggesting uh what we're
saying is it seems that most people are
more willing to have skilled migration
than unskilled migration you know you
you you're fine with some more doctors
coming in for the nihs because they're
actually going to help you know save you
or save your kids or something uh and
that's sort of okay it will be great for
those doctors because they'll come from
you know very poor countries and they
will may be much more productive in a UK
setting and that will make them better
off and they were part of the developing
world or the global South and now
they've become richer that's what we
want it to uh to happen they've also
become more productive they also help us
with our we have few kids and that's
eventually going to turn into a problem
it also helps the poor world you know
you think what about it's brain drain
you were basically taking away a doctor
but we know that they're also going to
send a lot of remittances back home
because that's how most people end up
acting and that will more than outweigh
the fact that they're lost in their
original country so overall we find that
allowing a little more skilled migration
so we're suggesting 10 percent more than
what you normally have so Canada has a
lot of immigrants they would presumably
be willing to take 10 more of a fairly
High number whereas some other countries
don't want any immigration have very low
immigration so they would take 10
percent more of a very low number this
is plausible but again I'm not arguing
that this is totally without political
implications but if you have skilled
migration 10 more it'll cost a couple
billion dollars but it'll generate more
than 20 billion dollars in in benefits
for the world and it'll actually reduce
uh inequality uh somewhat yeah it's not
a solution or anything but it's actually
a pretty good deal uh so sorry I I said
it's sorry 20 22 billion dollars and 40
billion dollars it's about 20 uh back in
the dollar and what would you say about
the brain drain argument that what
you're effectively doing is taking a
country's brightest and best
transplanting them into a country that
is already wealthy which is going to
generate more and more more tax dollars
for that country but actually those
people the doctors that thinkers the
economists are really needed in this
country over here because they're the
people going to help lift it out of
poverty yes that is a correct argument
but as as I also pointed out the
remittances and much of this remittance
will be used to teach to the Next
Generation it is it it outweighs the
loss two to one so it's actually
probably a good idea even for the
sending country but it's not nearly as
good an idea as it is for the rich
country that receives this person and
for the person uh him or herself so
there's there's definitely political
issues and it's also one of the the
chapters that are least obvious so again
yeah we're economists we tried to Simply
say this is what the numbers tell us uh
we're well aware and that's yeah we we
made that abundantly clear some
economists would say open up the entire
world have you know 2.4 billion people
who move to the rich West uh and you're
like really really uh but you know
that's not what we're saying but we are
suggesting this would still be a good
idea uh whether you want to do it at the
end of the day is a political issue well
that's right so you're giving the
economic assessment of the impact of
that and then there's political
Dimension to that there's a cultural
Dimension to that and that is for the
society to talk about and decisions just
to give you a sense of of what we're
really trying to do we want to put
prices and sizes on society's menu right
we want to tell tell you when you talk
about oh we could get rid of cancer or
we could get rid of plastic straws or
climate change or whatever there's rally
cost associated with that you don't
actually see so how much is this going
to cost you but maybe you'd want to know
that just like if you go into a
restaurant you'd like to know you know
how much is this caviar are going to
cost me oh 2 000 pounds maybe I'm not
gonna you know pick that that so we put
prices and sizes on the society's menu
and then you decide whether you actually
want to pay for it Bjorn it's been an
absolutely fascinating conversation so
good to have you back before we go to
the local section where our audience
have already submitted questions for you
that we'll ask and before we ask you are
very last question the most obvious
question to ask you is this it's twofold
if I'm an ordinary person I'm a plumber
I'm a podcast host I'm a YouTuber I'm a
comedian I'm a right whatever and I'm
listening to this what can I do and the
second part of that is if I'm a policy
maker and I'm in a position of influence
I'm in government I'm in the media what
can I do right default two-part question
I would wish I could say here is a
here's a link to donate yeah here you
should donate this this amount of money
we have not done that partly because
we're very aware of you know there's
very few organizations that sort of
straight on do exactly what we talk
about so I think the right answer is for
you know us normal people it's much more
to say simply you should keep talking
about these are the top priorities so
make sure that everybody else don't talk
about all this other stuff first but
simply talk about let's fix tuberculosis
malaria
immunization of of small kids education
agriculture research and development
e-procurement and these are the things
that I talk about in the book let's make
sure we focus on the really smart stuff
if you do that that's going to be worth
much more than you know an extra five
pounds it because it helps change the
political discourse to being smarter and
that of course goes to your other part
of the question so what should
policymakers do fund these things please
and and and it's important to say this
is not just about you know rich
countries spending more money because at
the end of the day we also want poor
countries to do this remember poor
countries have actually doubled their
spending per person in schools over uh
sorry per student uh over the last 25
years so they're spending a lot more
money and there's virtually nothing to
show for it a little bit like what you
were talking about and the rich West we
we're not seeing our uh education
results uh increase and some sometimes
actually decrease so you should spend it
smarter so it's not just a about
overseas development Aid it's also about
making sure that politicians in these
developing countries get with the
message uh we've actually I've I've been
fortunate enough to write in 35 papers
uh around the world so Times of India
China Daily Bangkok Post uh you know
Philippine daily Inquirer a lot of other
uh papers across Africa uh and Latin
America uh to write so I've written 14
articles so you know one about the
general priorities 12 about these 12
individual ideas and then sort of a
summary uh again this is not enough to
get everybody on board but it certainly
is the first push to get people to think
smarter about this if we all think
smarter this is not just going to fix
the 35 billion problem but it's also
going to make us smarter about all the
other challenges we face right because I
mean at the end of the day this is for
rich people it's just one percent it'd
be cool if we could get the other 99
well uh you know more better prioritized
absolutely and Beyond the question that
we always ask all I guess is what's the
one thing we're not talking about that
we really should be
and you told me before we started and
I'm I'm still a little black so I'm
gonna with go because there's a lot of
things we don't talk about but I really
think this book tells you about some of
those stories that we don't talk about
for obvious reasons we've talked about
we don't have tuberculosis but there's
lots of tuberculosis in the world we
don't talk about immunization but
there's lots of kids who still need
immunization we don't talk enough about
education because we you know we're
focused on all these other things like
plastic straws we should talk more about
education so really this I I'm just so
excited that this podcast may actually
have turned to tide and make us talk
more about the things that matter most
namely the things that kill enormous
amount of people and hold back
development and for 35 billion dollars
we can make the change Bjorn lombok
thank you for coming on best things
first make sure you grab this and find
out about it can I just say uh you can
actually see the conclusion on the cover
uh yes the cost is down here the benefit
is massive yes uh indeed Bjorn thank you
so much for coming back on the show it's
such a pleasure to have someone with a
positive Vision or and a realistic
Vision it's not just like oh yeah we
should be it's actually you're looking
at how to fix the problems of the world
I think that's exactly the attitude we
need so it's a real pleasure to have you
back thank you uh and uh head over to
locals where we're going to ask beyond
your questions we'll see you there
what do you think about AI
oh God
[Music]